[Musica]
Buon pomeriggio a tutti
disruptive Ambition è il titolo No di
questo tettoac quindi ambizione
dirompente sono due parole che hanno
caratterizzato la mia vita personale e
professionale finora tra alti e bassi
viaggi
carriere in altri settori mi sono
trovato a fare l'imprenditore a poco più
di tre anni fa e sono stato parte di
questa storia ho fondato quello che poi
è diventato un unicorno Cos'è un
unicorno una società con una valutazione
superiore al miliardo di dollari
si chiama unicorno perché è un è un
qualcosa no di non naturale un qualcosa
di piuttosto raro soprattutto almeno in
Italia in questo momento Poi ne sono
nati tanti tanti in giro per il mondo
però appunto una storia soprattutto in
Italia diversa da tante altre startup
che non ce l'hanno fatte Quindi questa
società è scala Pei e ha raccolto ad
oggi più di 600 milioni di dollari
appunto a questa valutazione
partire da zero Però non è non è mai
facile adesso no Semplice dire a Bravi
Ce l'avete fatta ma io ho ancora ricordo
poco più di tre anni fa quando lascio
Londra dove avevo trascorso tutta la mia
vita professionale e vado in un paesino
che si chiama Montelupo Fiorentino qui
in provincia di Firenze qui vicino e
ero abituato dico sempre questo aneddoto
che ha a dormire no in alberghi a 5
stelle dormir viaggiare in business
Class Perché lavoravo a goldman Sachs
Quindi questa banca d'affari dove era lo
standard e invece
con questa piccola società non avevamo
né fondi né altro e bisognava dormire
non bed and breakfast viaggiare in
economy e addirittura a un certo punto
sono stato costretto a chiedere un
prestito a mio padre cosa che non avrei
mai voluto fare più per orgoglio che
peraltro però mi sono trovato in quella
situazione Oggi è il 21 ottobre 2022 il
21 ottobre 2019
Forse eravamo in sei persone da
Montelupo Fiorentino c'eravamo
trasferiti a Milano quindi almeno un
passaggio l'abbiamo fatto però
pochissime persone avevamo raccolto
credo 800 mila euro e no c'era c'era
ancora una bella ancora una bella
scalata da fare e facciamo facendo festa
Fast Forward no tre anni dopo ci siamo
trovati adesso con 250 persone uffici in
tutto il mondo ha principalmente Milano
Parigi ancora tante persone a Sydney
però perché sono qui adesso non mi
voglio raccontare tutti i dettagli di
questa avventura ma
trasmettervi Quali sono stati i fattori
e le caratteristiche principali che ci
hanno differenziato da altre società che
magari non non ce l'hanno fatte fattori
che vengono studiati nei nostri libri di
scuola ma io li ho vissuti sulla
sulla mia pelle quindi partiamo dal
primo e forse un'ultima premessa non ci
sono delle cose universali ogni startup
differente ogni settore ha un suo perché
però una cosa che spesso viene
dimenticata è l'ascolto l'ascolto
cosa Cosa significa Noel saper saper
capire guardare un mercato
parlare con i clienti e capire quali
sono le necessità cosa cosa vogliamo
soddisfare quindi non per forza andare a
creare un qualcosa di nuovo una domanda
che non c'è tante volte sento degli
Imprenditori no con appunto di swap di
Ambition bisogna fare qualcosa di
speciale che non si è mai visto prima ma
io
almeno con questa società che è stata la
prima tra l'altro sono stato fortunato e
vedremo le prossime però ho preso un
settore già
esistente con il pagamento rateale
quindi un qualcosa che già tanti
facevano e vai a fare qualcosa in
maniera o migliore o a costi inferiori e
se a questo aggiungiamo poi una analisi
della competizione Quindi cosa cosa quel
mercato può offrire Quindi o magari Zero
competizione o due una competizione che
io chiamo dinosauro Quindi resti al
cambiamento comunque necessità di tempo
quello può essere no un mercato perfetto
per per entrare per crescere rapidamente
un esempio è mi vien da pensare starlink
che con la sua tecnologia
satellitare offre No la offre internet
nelle vostre case adesso principalmente
ancora in America però cosa fa non ha
creato nulla di nuovo ma è più veloce
costa di meno e i competitor sono
tendenzialmente lenti ad adeguarsi al
cambiamento e quindi mentre
sviluppano una situazione sulla una
soluzione simile loro già sono avanti
anni anni luce scala Pay è stato un po'
lo stesso entrando in un settore dove
pagamento rateale esisteva già in
Australia esisteva in Brasile da
tantissimi anni
abbiamo portato quel tasto Zero in
Italia dove c'erano anche delle società
Ma erano piccolissime e i nostri
competitor sono avrei potuto considerare
le banche sono appunto nolenti al
cambiamento dove passati tre anni ancora
non offrono Questo questo tipo di
servizio noi come l'abbiamo fatto
l'abbiamo fatto ascoltando appunto i
nostri clienti ai nostri clienti chi
sono Sono i venditori finali i venditori
finali
Quindi
chi ha un e-commerce che ha un negozio
fisico cose bravo a fare è bravo a
produrre è bravo a fare marketing però
poi arriva quella parte no di concludere
l'acquisto il pagamento che la parte un
po' più fastidiosa No nessuno di voi a
nessuno di voi clienti finali invece
vorrebbe no poi cioè si trova di fronte
al pagamento però
[Musica]
al desiderio di tanti prodotti e poi no
bisogna pagare quindi cosa succede
scala Pay sia è andata ascoltare questa
necessità sia del venditore sia del
cliente è andata a connettere i due e
quindi offrendo la possibilità di
realizzare quel pagamento quindi con un
carrello da 600 euro
l'oratesi in tre 200 oggi 200 domande
2003 al mese 2003 due mesi e per il
cliente molto più semplice di dire ok
pago 200 oggi quindi è come un po' avere
la tredicesima e è completo più acquisti
aumento il carrello medio avendo la
conversione E da lì è stato un successo
quindi primo fattore no ascoltare
sviluppare un prodotto è un mercato
Quindi avere prorot e Market fit
ma adesso viene l'execution tante
società sono in grado di sviluppare un
prodotto di trovare un mercato iniziare
a fare anche dei ricavi interessanti e
poi si bloccano
vi dico due dati di che ho visto nella
di recente nel Regno Unito
delle startup create non negli ultimi
negli ultimi anni dopo cinque anni il
20% non esiste più fallisce finiscono i
fondi cambiano completamente quello che
fanno però non sono più lì a fare lo
stesso business il
forse la cosa più interessante però è
impressionante che il 55% poi
entra in una fase di stagnazione quindi
a parte quelle 20 che falliscono altre
55 si trovano una situazione che forse
ancora più pericolosa perché fallisci
dopo due tre anni ti metti a fare
qualcos'altro ma invece hai dei ricavi
Ma non riesci a scalare e
hai difficoltà a raccogliere capitali e
quindi essendo poi una società privata
ti aspetteresti quantomeno No una
quotazione in borsa o una Exit o
un'operazione di m&m Emergency che non
arriverà mai o almeno non arriva dopo 5
anni
execution dunque come come si fa
Noi siamo stati
bravissimi a
raccogliere quel capitale necessario per
per aiutarci in in quella crescita e i
momenti più importanti sono stati ad
aprile del 2021 quando è arrivato il
primo fondo internazionale che Tiger
Global investendo più di 100 milioni in
noi e già valutandoci più di 500 milioni
di euro e poi diciamo la Consacrazione è
arrivata a inizio di quest'anno con
tencent che il fondo è anche dietro Tik
Tok per intenderci e a con ulteriore
capitale appunto portato a questa
valutazione di
oltre un miliardo
però questo successo
non arriva subito e va
e arriva diciamo è va costruito E quando
vado nelle università molto spesso mi
capita di parlare con questi ragazzi no
di appena 20 anni e dicono Ah ce le hai
fatte te ce l'ha fatta te ce l'ha fatta
a scalapei o adesso no satispay o
bending Spoon tante belle realtà
italiane che hanno raccolto capitali
importanti Ok Adesso voglio fare
l'imprenditore
non è sempre così e almeno non è nel mio
caso io
a 18 anni sono andato vengo da un
paesino in provincia di Salerno sono
andato via di casa Sono andato alla
Bocconi ho fatto lì l'università ma
appena laureato Sono andato subito a
lavorare a Londra a Londra ho fatto una
carriera in banca d'affari Barclays poi
Colman saphs e poi ho lavorato in un
fondo di private Equity Quindi tutta
questa esperienza mi è servita poi per
per lavorare su questa execution tanti
ragazzi si hanno questa idea però poi si
bloccano e non sanno e non sanno
scalarla e allora lì Viene anche
l'importanza del team perché non dico
ragazzo di 22 anni ho la ragazza di 22
anni non fare start up però se lo fai
Circondati anche di persone con un certo
tipo di esperienza che possano aiutarti
in
in questa scalata perché altrimenti ti
blocchi e ti blocchi in una in una
questa fase no di stagnazione come come
questo 55% di società che vi menzionavo
Quindi ora abbiamo provato abbiamo
Market abbiamo le execution
cosa manca manca
un fattore importante che lo chiamo
fattore c fattore culo e senza quello
non si va non si va da nessuna parte
purtroppo
bisogna bisogna trovare un'onda in
maniera più poetica Bisogna saperla
cavalcare quest'onda se fossimo entrati
Non lo so in un settore come i serbatoi
per motori a scoppio dove ci sta ci sta
muovendo No verso l'elettrico
probabilmente non avremmo avuto questi
questo successo e questa raccolta
capitali e invece siamo entrati in un
mercato di pagamenti e la nostra fortuna
è brutto da dire è stato il covip perché
e tra l'altro in due modi perché la
prima parte è riferita anche la raccolta
capitale ancora ricordo era
febbraio 2020 Quindi no due anni
all'inizio proprio del due anni e mezzo
fa e eravamo in piena raccolta capitali
stavamo finendo tutti i nostri fondi e
cosa succede Corvina Cina covid in
Italia
tutti gli altri paesi no sembra la
stessero bene Io al momento ero a Londra
Boris Johnson lasciava andare a vedere
le partite allo stadio a Premier League
funzionava e quindi i due appestati
erano a cena in Italia potete immaginare
noi che abbiamo una captable
completamente quasi interamente
straniera quindi investitori da New York
o da Sydney o da Londra che ci avevano
promesso capitale dicono no non
investiamo più perché perché non
sappiamo cosa succederà in Italia Mentre
gli altri paesi stanno bene
difficilissimo anche di nuovo siamo
tornati da Family and Friends no poi
persone che che adesso ci ringraziano
però ci hanno dato dei piccoli capitali
ma messi assieme ci hanno permesso di
andare avanti qualche altro mese poi la
pandemia
non è finita ma quantomeno sia allentata
ma qual è stato il beneficio
a livello economico nel nostro settore
della pandemia è stato un boom dell'
e-commerce quindi persone non potevano
uscire di casa comprano online e
comprando online essendoci incertezza
come preferiscono pagare tutto subito o
dilazionare il pagamento ovviamente
dilazionare il pagamento e quindi
abbiamo avuto dei volumi importantissimi
una crescita colossale che dà appunto
quasi fallire a febbraio no a portarci
un anno dopo a queste raccolte di
capitali importanti Questa è stata per
noi l'onda l'abbiamo cavalcata con un
grande team e ci ha portato
ad oggi nella situazione nella
situazione in cui siamo Quindi questi
sono un po' i tre fattori ma venendo al
punto iniziale la raccolta
capitali il timing È veramente
importante e
ogni società
è diversa ogni società deciderà quando
quando pensa si opportuna raccogliere
questo capitale Nel nostro caso nel mio
non c'erano fondi quindi mi sono trovato
andare prestissimo dal mercato e anche
dare una quota importante della società
Ma se posso dare un consiglio a nuovi
startupper
se hanno dei fondi o comunque se possono
posticipare il suggerimento è sempre
quello di non iniziare subito e
raccogliere su un'idea ma magari
sviluppare un prodotto una tecnologia e
iniziare a fare ricavi anche mille euro
al mese possono bastare per
avere un interesse diverso un interesse
su un qualcosa di concreto soprattutto
in un mercato dove come come quello di
Herno dove non si non si pensa più una
crescita impossibile infinita ma si
pensa più alla profittabilità ad aziende
ad aziende sostenibili e anche quello di
non
andare a costruire subito un aereo una
un'auto Ma magari partire da altri cicli
o passare alla bicicletta e così via
quindi step by step mandare sul mercato
piccoli prodotti prima che ci sia quello
completo finale che magari
richiederebbe tantissimo tempo e
tantissime risorse questa cosa in un
mercato soprattutto come quello di oggi
è difficile e io personalmente eviterei
quindi un po' per concludere la ricetta
per il successo non c'è
ogni ogni startup ha una situazione a sé
Però secondo me se si ascolta Se siate
curiosi se avete persone Capaci mi
circondate di queste persone Capaci e un
mercato che
sia sia dalla vostra parte e tanta tanta
determinazione si vedranno tantissimi
unicorni unicorni questa volta
sostenibili Grazie a tutti
[Applauso]